J. MICHAEL MCBRIDE: OK, more on
addition to alkenes.
In particular today we're
talking about cycloaddition,
addition to make rings.
So we'll talk more about
epoxides.
Then ozonolysis and how acetals
play a role in
ozonolysis.
And then we'll get on, I hope,
to transition metal catalysis,
hydrogenation and
polymerization.
So we're talking-- and remember
reaction with
alkenes, the reagents are called
electrophilic, but
they're nucleophilic as well.
And we've talked about these,
and at the end last time we
were talking about epoxidation,
which we'll
continue with now.
And then about ozonolysis and
about things attached to
metals-- hydrogen attached to
metals, and alkyl groups
attached to metals.
So this is where we were last
time.
Remember there were a whole
bunch of arrows we drew
happening all at the same time,
although
not in perfect synchrony.
Some were a little more
established at the transition
state than others.
Now after class I was asked
wouldn't have been simpler to
abbreviate arrows, as in
textbooks, so you don't draw
quite as many arrows.
I didn't point this out, but
there was a reason I drew so
many arrows.
You might imagine that you could
abbreviate it this way,
which shows the electrons here
forming a bond, the electrons
here going to here to make a
double bond.
This double bond coming down
here to make a single bond.
And this bond coming over here.
That accounts for all the
electron pairs, but it doesn't
account for them properly, and
the reason it doesn't is some
of them are pi and some of them
are sigma.
So it can't be the same electron
pair that's being
both pi in the plane of the ring
and sigma in the plane of
the ring, and pi out of the
plane of the ring.
So I accounted for the electrons
differently in
drawing those arrows as to which
kind was doing what.
So at the very end last time we
were talking about ethylene
oxide, how it was a big item of
commerce, 20 million tons a
year and $20 billion, because of
the
importance of ethylene glycol.
Then we were going to see how
you get ethylene glycol from
either base or acid catalysis
with water on ethylene oxide.
So let's start with base
catalysis.
Where's it going to attack?
Po-Yi, what do you say?
Where will OH minus attack
ethylene oxide?
What kind of reaction's going to
happen?
STUDENT: It will attach onto
hydrogen, CH molecule.
PROFESSOR: OK, so you want to
take off a proton, is that
right, to attack a hydrogen so
as to remove a proton?
Attack sigma* CH, is that
the idea?
STUDENT: Yeah.
PROFESSOR: Now the problem with
that is that the anion
you get is not at all a good
anion.
It's a carbon anion.
The hybridization makes it
better than most carbon
anions, but not that much
better.
My guess is its pKa is some
place in the 40s, whereas the
pKa OH minus, or of water to
give OH minus is 16, right--
15 and a half.
So that there's whatever that
is, a 25 powers of 10
difference.
So it's going to be very hard to
pull off a proton, even
though hydroxide, you're right,
is a strong base--
better as a base than what you
would expect for its
nucleophilicity.
So how about another
possibility?
If it's not going to be CH
sigma*, what will attack?
Now of course, ethylene oxide is
an ether.
And ethers don't usually undergo
displacement because
it's a bad leaving group.
O minus is not a great leaving
group, RO minus.
But this is a special case.
Can you see why?
Anybody else got an idea?
Arvind?
STUDENT: Is it because of the
strain of the--
PROFESSOR: High strain, right,
will make that bond weak.
So, in fact, it is a backside
attack, an SN2 reaction on the
CO sigma*, which opens the
ring because of the ring
strain to give that.
And now that, of course, picks
up a proton from water, the
pKa's are essentially the same
for an alcohol and water and
generates ethylene glycol, the
item of commerce we were
interested in making.
Now suppose we're going to do
with H+ catalysis.
Who's got an idea for that one?
Rahul, you've got an idea?
How is H+ going to get into the
act?
STUDENT: It's a low LUMO so it's
going to be
attacked by a high HOMO.
So the oxygen.
PROFESSOR: What about oxygen?
STUDENT: The lone pairs.
PROFESSOR: Right, the lone pair
on the oxygen.
So it'll come down, attack the
lone pair on the
oxygen to get this.
And now what do you expect for
the reactivity of this thing?
Rahul, keep us going.
STUDENT: There's still ring
strain, right?
PROFESSOR: There's still a ring
strain, and you've got a
much better leaving group now--
O plus [correction: OH]
rather than going to become O
minus.
So now even water can do it.
It doesn't have to be hydroxide.
So we got a great leaving group,
water comes in the does
the trick, and again, we get it.
So either acid or base catalysis
with water will
convert ethylene oxide into
ethylene glycol.
But there's another possibility
for a nucleophile
in the system, which is this O
minus.
So you could imagine it coming
down there and doing the
trick, and now you get another O
minus that can attack again,
another O minus that could
attack again.
So you can get a whole bunch of
these CH2-CH2-O-CH2-CH2-O's
strung together.
So you can get a polyether.
There can be as few as three to
call it poly, although
often you'd call that oligo,
meaning a few.
But up to 20,000 units or more
can be strung
together that way.
And these things are big items
in commerce as solvents among
other things.
They're also used in toothpaste,
in paintball and
lots of different applications.
Here's another application.
So you can take the trimer--
that's three of the CH2O's put
together.
And it's been treated with
potassium
hydroxide to make the salt.
And you could treat another one
of the alcohols with one
of the agents to convert OH into
Cl, like thionyl chloride
and get a dichloride.
Can you see what I'm after here?
What kind of reaction do I want
to do?
Ellen?
STUDENT: SN2?
PROFESSOR: Right, SN2.
It's a Williamson ether
synthesis, RO minus reacting
with RCl to make a an O-C bond.
And what's the product going to
be?
STUDENT: A crown ether.
PROFESSOR: Right, that's how
18-crown-6 is made.
And in fact, this is what's
called an Org.
Syn.
prep.
Org.
Syn. is Organic Syntheses.
Every year they put out one of
these volumes--
I'll pass around so you can look
at them-- which have
various interesting preparations
that have been
proposed by competent chemists
and tested by them to make
sure they work.
Here's another one, you can send
it back the other way.
So you can see each of these has
the order of 20 really
good, careful descriptions with
lots of information about
exactly how you do it, where you
get the starting
materials, and lots and lots of
footnotes.
So textbooks don't have time to
do this.
And original publications in the
paper often haven't been
carefully checked.
But if you want to see how a
reaction is really carried
out, this is a very good source
and it tells you
exactly what faithful yields
are, not ones that have been
exaggerated.
And one of the Org.
Syn.
preps is of 18-crown-6.
It's interesting, and you might
think about that, that
they used the potassium salt,
the potassium hydroxide was
the one they made the dianion
with.
You might think why that might
be.
Well actually, incidentally, if
you click on that you will
get this, which is the
description of how to make
18-crown-6 on the web from Org.
Syn.
So that's how we open ethylene
glycol.
Now, notice that if the epoxide
is unsymmetrical--
substituted on one side and not
the other--
then there are two different
ways of attacking.
For example, in the textbook it
shows that you could attack
the less substituted or the more
substituted.
And it says in acid the
nucleophile generally becomes
attached to the more substituted
carbon.
In base the nucleophile
generally becomes attached to
the less substituted carbon.
So this is obviously a
generality.
And one would be interested in
seeing precise data to see
just how selective it is.
So here's an example from the
book where they used sodium
amide [correction: sodium
azide].
So N3 minus is the nucleophile.
And indeed here, with the anion
attacking it attacks the
less substituted, as you would
expect in an SN2, and gives a
41% yield of the product from
attacking the
less substituted carbon.
Now, do you find that then
convincing in terms of in acid
you attack one and in base you
attack the other?
Noah, what do you say?
STUDENT: No.
41% yield really isn't very much
yield.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Now of course, you've been in
lab, and I wouldn't be
surprised that from time to time
you've been
happy with a 41% yield.
Right?
So if you really do get 41%--
remember we've talked about one
synthesis
where 5% was plenty.
So from a point of preparative--
being able to make the stuff--
41% sounds pretty good.
But if you're interested in does
it really support that
generalization, with base
catalysis that is, anion
attacking, you attack the less
substituted one, you'd want to
know what the other 59% is.
If the other 59% were attacking
the other carbon
that would be bad news for this
generalization.
So one has to be careful in
reading textbooks, because
often references aren't given
about that 41%.
So here's a generalization that
says that-- here's the
other example with acid
catalysis.
So it says when you attack with
acid, indeed, the
chloride goes more on the more
substituted carbon.
That's what the generalization
was.
But notice that the product
ratio is 55% to 45%.
It's not 99:1.
It then explains it by saying if
the charge is on the more
substituted carbon, that is when
you protonate the O, the
bridge is unsymmetrical--
we've talked about that--
with more charge on the more
substituted carbon so that's
the one that gets attacked.
"That's where the nucleophile
adds." as it says.
But notice that this is a tough
thing to generalize, not
a very reliable example to
generalize with, the 55:45.
Because that ratio is 10^0.09,
which means that the
difference in activation energy
for going one way and
going the other at room
temperature is 0.12
kilocalories per mole.
And you're sophisticated enough
by now to know that
that's nothing.
That's only 1/25 as big as a
hydrogen bond.
So it's true that it gives more
of the more substituted
one in this particular case, but
you wouldn't feel very
confident in interpreting that.
So you might do a calculation to
see what the minimum energy
geometry is for such a
protonated epoxide.
This is not a really high
quality calculation.
And it's in the gas phase, and,
of course, where a
solvent is can make a lot more
difference than 0.12
kilocalories per mole.
But anyhow, you could look and
see where positive things
would like to be or negative
things would like to be on the
van der Waals surface of this
molecule.
So if you look up here at the
top, remarkably enough, when
you drew this structure you draw
it O plus--
it's a trivalent oxygen, the O
of the three-membered ring has
been protonated.
So you draw O plus.
But notice that this is the
energy a proton would have on
the surface of that.
It's high near the oxygen, but
it's 120 kilocalories higher
near the hydrogen.
That's the worst place to put a
positive charge.
So it's not what you would draw
if you just put a plus
charge on the oxygen.
So that's the worst place for
H+.
It would be the best place for a
negatively charged
nucleophile.
So the best thing would be to
pull the
proton back off again.
On the other hand, you could, if
you turn the molecule
upside-down from the top right
and look at the bottom of it,
you see the two carbons that
could be attacked.
And at that place, the energy
for the proton would be +140;
there it would be +141.5.
So it's true that it's a little
bit more positive near
the central part, near the more
substituted carbon, but
not very much.
And of course, it's sterically
hindered there.
So it seems to be very touchy to
try to interpret this.
But still, there are many
examples where it is more
dramatic than that.
Here, for example, are cases
from the textbook where a
carbon nucleophile does the
attack.
Now you notice that when the
phenyl attached to copper
attacks so that the polarization
is such that the
phenyl is mostly minus, so it's
the nucleophile, although
it's really more complicated
because the copper's around at
the same time.
But notice it attacks backside
and it gives a 98% yield.
So that's the kind of thing when
you see it in the book
that you can say ah-ha, that's
really something.
55:45 is not the basis for
confident interpretation.
98% is more like it.
Or in this other example where
it's 85:8 attack at one
position versus the other with
base catalysis, attacking, as
the generalization had said, at
the less substituted carbon
to give the 85% product.
So there are plenty of examples
that support this
generalization, but it's not
always reliable.
It's important to be critical in
looking at the evidence
that people provide to support
their generalizations.
So that one shows
stereospecificity.
The other one shows
regiospecificity, and much
more impressive than that 55:45
example; 85:8 is much
more practical for synthesis
purposes and much more
convincing for interpretation
purposes.
So that much for the epoxides.
Now onto ozonolysis, which takes
us into other examples
of cycloaddition.
Of course, forming the epoxide
is a three-membered ring, so
it is a cycloaddition that forms
a ring.
But ozone is more interesting
because it's three atoms. So
we can imagine this shift of
electron pairs, perhaps
happening all at the same time,
to make a
five-membered ring.
And on the left is the
arrangement of those atoms in
the transition state, as
calculated by quantum mechanics.
So we could look at the motion
along the reaction coordinate,
both face on here, the side
view, as I said, and
also the end view.
Notice that O3 is bent so that
the central oxygen is not as
near the carbons being attacked
as the terminal
oxygens are.
So now watch, and we'll watch it
move.
So the oxygens move down, the
carbons move up
and form the bond.
We'll reverse it and go back and
forth several times.
So you can see it's another one
of these cases where it
looks like the attacking group
is rotating down toward the
carbon as the carbon moves up.
So notice everything is
happening at the same time.
It's not that you form one bond
and then the other bond.
So let's look at the orbitals
that are involved in making
two new bonds at the same time,
so there must be two
electron pairs that are
involved.
So there we have the LUMO on O3,
and the HOMO on ethylene.
Remember that that central
oxygen up on top is not
getting into the act, it's back
behind the screen.
So you see the two reds with the
LUMO on top are in
position to make good overlap.
And then give this orbital at
the transition state,
which is the HOMO--
those overlapping with one
another--
to be bonding, and that's one
electron pair.
So that would account for one
bond.
But by the same token you have
the LUMO of the alkene on the
bottom right interacting with
the HOMO of O3 up on top.
And those overlap well and give
the HOMO-1.
So another pair of electrons
gets stabilized as these atoms
come together.
So two electron pairs get
stabilized,
two bonds are formed.
Now this is cycloaddition of
allylic 1,3-dipole to alkenes.
There are other examples besides
ozone.
Now a 1,3-dipole is a thing like
You may remember that in the
third lecture, way back at the
beginning of the fall, we talked
about drawing valence
structures for ozone, and the
fact that the lowest energy
structure is not a
three-membered
ring, but an open form.
The interesting thing about it
is when you draw Lewis
structures you can't draw a
structure that doesn't have
charges or free radicals on the
atoms. So those examples
are shown there.
So these things are called
1,3-dipoles.
There are three atoms in a row
and all the structures you can
draw are dipolar.
But that's not the only example.
Here on an exam from several
years ago, I asked the
question saying, "Having learned
that the allylic pi
system of O3"--
remember, allylic means three p
orbitals overlapping in a
row, that's allylic and that's,
obviously, the case
with ozone.
So, "Having learned that allylic
pi system of ozone
forms two bonds at once to an
alkene, as shown" bottom left
there, "one might think to try
the same thing with the
apparently analogous boron
compound."
I'm not actually confident that
that molecule
exists, but it might.
"Explain in terms of the
orbitals involved why this
might not" work.
It looks like the same thing.
You have a 1,3-dipole on the
right, and we draw curved
arrows to make the two new
bonds, we have a 1,3-dipole on
the left and we draw curved
arrows to make the new bonds.
But why wouldn't the one on the
right work?
Let's try to do a theoretical
analysis of that.
So here's ozone viewed from the
top.
Now if we rotate this central
oxygen at the top back to see
the p orbitals we see that there
are three p orbitals in
a row, an allylic system.
The lowest-energy pi orbital
then will have them all
overlapping favorably with one
another.
That will be Psi-1, the lowest-
energy pi orbital.
It has no antibonding node.
And the middle atomic orbital
will be largest. We can choose
the size of the p orbitals of
the three.
There's an advantage to making
the one--
the sum of their squares has to
be one.
What do you call that condition,
you remember?
STUDENT: Nomalization.
PROFESSOR: Normalization, right.
That the electron has to be
somewhere with the total
probability of one.
So the sum of the squares has to
be one, but they don't have
to be the same size.
Symmetry would suggest that the
two ends should be the
same size, but the one in the
middle could
be smaller or bigger.
And I say that it's a little bit
bigger.
Why should it be bigger?
Why do you get advantage by
having the one in the middle
big compared to the ones at the
end, if the sum of their
squares is fixed?
What you want to get is bonding,
overlap.
So the bigger the orbitals the
more overlap.
What's special about the one in
the middle?
Why do you want to make it
bigger?
Lauren?
STUDENT: Because it's bonded to
two of them?
PROFESSOR: It overlaps twice.
Good.
So then the next one has a node
in the middle-- that
doesn't surprise you.
And the highest one has two
nodes.
Now, I'm confused by this
because starting with three
atomic orbitals and making three
molecular orbitals, you
have to use up the three atomic
orbitals.
If you have more in one place
there has to be less in some
place else.
Obviously, there's none on the
middle oxygen in the one that
has no node.
That means that the others have
to have more of that and
less of what's on the end.
It doesn't appear that way in
this picture.
It doesn't appear that the
central one is big.
But, in fact, it has to be, and
I think this is some
artifact of the particular
contour that's been chosen,
and I can't really explain it.
But in general, the favorable
one, Psi-1, is as favorable as
it can be, big in the middle.
The second one with the node in
the middle is obviously
50:50 on the two ends.
And the top one will be big in
the middle to be as
antibonding as it can be.
When they were good they were
very, very good.
And when they were bad they were
horrid.
That's the way it works out.
So those are the three molecular
orbitals we're going
to be dealing with.
Now if you take another allylic
system like CH2BHCH2,
the one we were talking about,
we can look at its p orbitals
and there's Psi-1 and there's
Psi-2 and there's Psi-3, and
this one does, indeed, show
biggest in the middle, so
that's satisfying.
Of course, boron is less
electronegative than carbon,
less nuclear charge.
So you would expect the lowest
orbital not to have so much of
it, and the highest orbital to
have a lot of the less
favorable orbital.
Now if we look at a third
example, carbonyloxide, which
you notice is a carbonyl
compound, H2CO, formaldehyde,
with an extra oxygen on it.
And that turns out also to be a
1,3-dipole to be bent in the
structure shown.
And now it's not symmetrical end
to end.
So we see the same orbitals, but
they're distorted.
This one looks mostly like the C
double bond O, pi, but a
little bit of the oxygen on the
end.
That one has a node in it, and
that one is mostly the
antibonding pi* of carbonyl
with a little bit of
the oxygen on the end.
Now why should it be that way?
Well notice that the carbon is
much closer to the central
oxygen than the central oxygen
is to the terminal oxygen.
So the big interaction will be
between carbon
and the central oxygen.
So we could first look at the
interaction between carbon and
the central oxygen, and then
look at the interaction of
that, whatever we get from that
with the terminal oxygen,
because we'll look at the
strongest interaction first
and then at the weaker one.
So that says what I just said,
and it will make pi and
pi* out of that.
Now we're going to mix p-O, the
terminal oxygen, with pi
and pi*.
And we see it's closer to the pi
than to the pi* so we
get three new ones that look
like that.
There's less mixing at the top,
more mixing at the
bottom, a better energy match.
But Psi-1 still looks mostly
like the
lower energy one, pi-CO.
The pi* looks mostly like
pi* of CO.
And this one looks mostly like
the terminal oxygen.
That's just to show that the
orbitals are reasonable.
So that's big on pi and a little
bit of
the terminal oxygen.
That's that one.
Then you have one that's mostly
the terminal oxygen.
pi*.
Good.
Now let's look at how many pi
electrons we put in to these
systems. So we have to count
electrons.
So here we have three oxygens,
there are the sigma bonds, but
also unpaired electrons that are
sigma, in the plane
of the three O's.
And there are also then, if we
count up, electrons on the
terminal oxygens--
there's one more electron on
each of the terminal oxygens,
and two on the central oxygen.
So there are four electrons in
the pi system.
So in these pi orbitals we have
to put in four electrons.
So that's two pairs, and they go
into the lowest two
orbitals, of course.
So the HOMO is the middle
orbital, the
one with the node.
And the LUMO is the one with two
nodes.
Now suppose we're going to take
ozone and
react it with an alkene.
So we bring an alkene up, and
remember it touches the two
oxygens on the end, the ones in
front, not the one that's
behind the screen.
So that'll make a nice bond,
nice bonding interaction.
So the symmetry matches and we
get stabilization of one pair
of electrons.
But if we take the HOMO of the
alkene, it mixes with the LUMO
of the ozone.
So another pair of electrons
gets stabilized, and we make
two bonds at the same time and
make the five-membered ring.
So that's fine.
And as I said here, don't worry
about the oxygen in the
center, it doesn't overlap
because
it's behind the screen.
Now let's go over to look at the
carbonyl oxide and count
its electrons.
So that's the sigma electrons,
and in the pi there's one from
carbon, one from oxygen, and two
from the terminal oxygen.
So again, there are four
electrons, which means we're
going to occupy those two.
And again, the HOMO is going to
be the one with one node,
and the LUMO the one with two
nodes.
And when we bring the alkene up
it's going to do its trick.
So that's fine, too.
That'll form a five-membered
ring.
Now let's look at the other one,
the one that has boron in
the center.
So that one made two bonds.
Now the one with boron in the
center has just those two pi
electrons--
the boron's not contributing
anything.
So we have only two pi electrons
and we occupy only
the lowest of these orbitals.
So it's the HOMO and the middle
one is the LUMO.
Now you see when you bring
alkene in, it doesn't do the
same thing, because the HOMO of
the alkene looks just like
this and they're repulsive with
one another.
And the LUMO of the alkene looks
pretty much like this.
So it's HOMO with HOMO, LUMO
with LUMO to give overlap, and
nothing gets stabilized, it's
repulsive.
So that one won't do the trick.
There's no alkene-HOMO match
with that LUMO, and no
alkene-LUMO match with that
HOMO.
So the ones on the end will do
cycloadditions and give a
five-membered ring, but that one
with boron in the middle
won't because of how many pi
electrons it has.
So you can't make two bonds
simultaneously for
cycloaddition to the alkene of
that hypothetical compound.
Are there any questions about
that?
Does it seem unutterably
complicated?
Then review it.
So let's look at what happens
then in the process of
ozonolysis.
Incidentally, that name, the
lysis part means a loosening
or a breaking apart.
It seems a funny name, doesn't
it, for a cycloaddition which
is clearly bringing things
together.
But you'll see in a second what
happens, it's pretty neat.
So we bring alkene in and make
those two new bonds by
shifting the orbitals, as we
just were describing.
So we get this five-membered
ring.
But this isn't so stable.
Why is it not stable?
Wojciech, you got an idea?
STUDENT: All HOMOs.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, two oxygens in
a row of peroxide is bad.
Three oxygens in a row must be
even worse.
Remember what makes two oxygens
in a row bad?
STUDENT: Lone pairs.
PROFESSOR: The lone pairs
repelling.
And in this case, we've got--
this compound is called a
molozonide, if you have to give
it a name.
But it's unstable because of the
mixing of these HOMOs with
one another, the unshared pairs.
So that's really bad.
So it breaks apart.
Of course, it could break apart
just the way it formed.
But in fact, it breaks apart a
different way.
It draws these curved arrows,
which is the same kind of
thing we formed it with, but
we're breaking different bonds
from the one we formed.
We formed this bond and this
bond, and now we're breaking
this bond and this bond.
So it undergoes a reverse of the
previous
process to give that.
So that's an aldehyde, plus this
carbonyl oxide that we
saw on just the previous slide,
a 1,3-dipole.
But the carbonyl oxide can do a
cycloaddition.
So it could reverse this, but it
wouldn't because the
product would be unstable.
Do you see how to reverse it and
make the product more
stable where you don't have
three oxygens in a row?
Anybody got an idea?
How could you make the
cycloaddition go, of the
1,3-dipole to the double bond,
and not have three
oxygens in a row?
Elisa?
STUDENT: You'd use the thing you
just formed...
PROFESSOR: Can't hear you.
STUDENT: Use what you just
formed instead
of the three O's?
PROFESSOR: Use what you just
formed instead of the three
O's, I'm not quite sure what you
mean.
STUDENT: You react to the CH2-OO
to make the ring.
PROFESSOR: Aha.
React the CH2 with O. In other
words, you could turn that
molecule over and now do the
cycloaddition and you'd get
this form, which only has two
oxygens in a row.
That's the product that you
actually get by reacting O3
with the alkene.
Now this ozonide, as it's
called-- remember that first
one with three oxygens in a row
was called a molozonide,
this one's called an ozonide.
That's not so fantastically
important, but it's
what they call them.
This I call here a double
acetal.
Now an acetal is a carbon that
has two oxygens on it, two
ether oxygens.
So you've got that one, but you
also have that one, so
it's a double acetal.
You can hydrolyze acetals with
acid.
So we're going to go through and
figure out the mechanism
of that as another practice in
using curved arrows.
So Natalie, I want you to start
us.
It's acid catalyzed.
So what's going to be the very
first step?
STUDENT: To introduce your
proton, and your proton is the
LUMO, and so and your lone pair
on the oxygen--
PROFESSOR: OK.
So the proton will attack an
unshared pair on the oxygen.
Good.
Now what's our goal?
They'll be lots of different
things we can do as we go
along, but as we try to
formulate a mechanism, it's
important to remember what kind
of thing
we're trying to do.
And the kind of thing we're
aiming toward is to remove RO
and replace it with HO.
That's the goal of the first
step.
So you got us started well.
We take a proton, come down and
attack the unshared pair
and we get that.
Now what's the next step?
Natalie, can you help us some
more?
STUDENT: You have your hold the
positive charge on the
oxygen is your HOMO.
PROFESSOR: Now the positive
charge, remember, makes a
HOMO, makes orbitals be high,
[correction: low] in energy.
But the positive charge is not
an
orbital, it's just a charge.
What particular electrons or
what particular vacant orbital
would that be?
We want a low vacant orbital.
The plus charge will lower
orbitals.
What's the low orbital that
we're going for?
STUDENT: pi*.
PROFESSOR: There aren't any pi
electrons in
this, no double bonds.
STUDENT:sigma*.
PROFESSOR: sigma*.
So the CO sigma*.
So we can do this.
Have you ever seen a reaction
like that before?
Where a leaving group leaves and
leaves a cation?
Anybody seen a reaction like
that?
Alex?
STUDENT: SN1.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's an SN1 reaction where the
leaving group leaves-- we
made it a good leaving group by
putting the
positive charge on there.
Now that's a primary cation.
That doesn't look like a very
good candidate for SN1.
Alex, do you see any reason why
SN1 might be feasible?
Why that cation might be better
than you would imagine?
I could tell you a reason why
it's bad.
Oxygen is electron withdrawing--
right, high nuclear charge.
So it tends not to let cations
form.
It pulls electrons.
Why is that a good cation?
Anybody else got a suggestion?
Debby?
STUDENT: The electrons on the O
are stabilized.
PROFESSOR: The electrons of the
adjacent oxygen get
stabilized.
The unshared pair on the oxygen
get stabilized.
We can draw that resonance
structure.
So it is an unusually stable
cation, not because C+ is
stable, but because that low
vacant orbital stabilizes the
oxygen electrons next door.
So we get that cation.
And now we have-- it's
hydrolysis.
So water is going to get into
the act, form a new bond, and
we have this.
And we've done what we wanted to
do here.
Remove RO and replace it with
OH.
Of course, we replaced it with
H2O, but that's no problem, we
could lose the proton to another
water molecule.
So we've done the first step
here.
We have what's called a half
acetal, a hemiacetal.
Remember an acetal had two RO
groups attached to CH2.
Now we only have one, the other
is OH, a hemiacetal.
Now this whole process here, if
you had to give it a name,
a mechanistic name, what would
you call it Alex?
SN1.
OK.
So it's an SN1 reaction.
And now the second goal is to
remove the second RO, then a
proton from OH, and then we're
going to generate
a double bond here.
We're going to get CO double
bond.
So again, we have acid
catalysis.
Where are we going to attack for
this purpose?
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Attack the oxygen
pi*.
PROFESSOR: Right.
That's the one we want to lose,
so we protonate there.
Next step, Ruoyi?
STUDENT: Lose the alcohol.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So it's another SN1 kind of
thing
where we make the cation.
And now what's the last step if
we want to lose-- remember,
we want to lose H, too, from
here.
We just do it, right?
And what would you call that
process, the one that went
from here to here, if you had to
give it a mechanistic name?
Ruoyi?
STUDENT: E1.
PROFESSOR: That's E1, right,
formation of the cation.
So the process is E1.
OK, so that did it.
What we've done, the overall
transformation is to take
water plus an acetal, acid
catalysis, and get a carbonyl
plus two ROH's--
the one here and the one up
there.
So we started with the acetal
and water, and the water comes
across and we get two alcohols
and a carbonyl, just by the
SN1 and E1 mechanisms that we
just worked through.
So that's how you hydrolyze an
acetal.
And here's an acetal.
The CH2 has two O's in it.
So we can hydrolyze it.
And we can hydrolyze that one.
We can hydrolyze both--
the one on the right and the one
on the left.
And you see then what we've
done-- now you see the lysis
part, the breaking apart.
What was the starting material?
Where were these carbons in the
starting material, the
very early, before we added
ozone?
It was an alkene, a C-C double
bond.
What we've done is break the C-C
double bond and make two
C-O double bonds.
So that's the lysis part, the
breaking apart.
We change a C-C double bond into
two C-O double bonds.
But notice that one of the
byproducts is water, the other
one is hydrogen peroxide, which
is an oxidizing agent.
So it gives two carbonyl
compounds
and hydrogen peroxide.
But it turns out that hydrogen
peroxide oxidizes aldehydes
to carboxylic acids.
So this is a problem.
You don't just get the two
carbonyls, you also have
something that can react with
the aldehyde, the carbonyl.
So now, as the book points out,
and any of your books
will give this, there are two
ways you can
cope with this problem.
One is if you want to make the
aldehyde, put something else
in that will react with the
hydrogen peroxide
to get rid of it.
So you use a reducing agent, and
we'll talk shortly about
oxidizing and reducing agents.
But things like dimethyl sulfide
or zinc, which
destroys the HOOH.
So the book now gives examples
where you see you could do
this, first treat it with ozone
to get the ozonide.
Then treat it with water, but
with zinc there in order to
reduce the hydrogen peroxide.
And now you get the aldehyde in
93%.
That's the kind of yield that's
really convincing.
Or here's another example where
this one is first
ozonized, and then when it's
hydrolized it's treated with
the sulfur to get rid of the
hydrogen peroxide, and it
gives a 75% yield of this
aldehyde, and also the other
one, CH2O from the other side of
the double bond.
The other possibility is just go
with the flow.
If it's going to oxidize, fine,
put in
more oxidizing agent.
So there we use the dimethyl
sulfide and there zinc as
reducing agents.
But if you add more hydrogen
peroxide, as is done here, then
you can make the carboxylic acid
in reasonably good yield,
like this one, for example, 85%
yield.
So those are the two
possibilities with ozonolysis.
You break the CC double bond,
but the carbons could become
either carbonyls or carboxylic
acids.
Now how does that happen?
How does the aldehyde react with
hydrogen peroxide to give
carboxylic acid?
So let's try another mechanism
here.
Derek, you're going to start us
in.
What's going to react
with what here?
What's the HOMO, and what's
the LUMO?
STUDENT: Well, the minus on the
O is a HOMO.
PROFESSOR: The minus on the O is
a HOMO.
STUDENT: Would this be a double,
like
two at the same time?
PROFESSOR: Let's suppose we
aren't that sophisticated.
STUDENT: Then C double bond O is
the LUMO.
PROFESSOR: C double bond O
pi* is a good example.
Where would it attack, the C or
the O?
STUDENT: It would attack the C.
PROFESSOR: Attack the C, OK.
So there we go.
That's going to give this.
Now, can you think of a second
reaction?
Matt, let's go to you.
STUDENT: All right.
Well, the--
PROFESSOR: Where do we have a
HOMO?
STUDENT: You have a HOMO on the
unshared pair on the O.
PROFESSOR: So here's the HOMO,
where's the LUMO?
STUDENT: LUMO would be the OO
sigma*.
PROFESSOR: sigma* OO.
So we can do an SN2 kind of
reaction, right?
Like that.
That what you had in mind?
STUDENT: Yes.
PROFESSOR: And it's going to
form a three-membered ring
with two oxygens next to one
another.
That's not so great, because the
oxygen-oxygen's not a
strong bond and the
three-membered ring is going
to be strained.
So that was a reasonable idea,
that's why I
wrote it that way.
But if I had written it a
different way, the OO bond is
weak and the three-membered ring
is even
worse, so forget that.
So I'll write a different
conformation.
And now this is a neat reaction.
Again we're going to use
sigma* OO with OH the
leaving group.
It's a weak bond, OO.
But now we're doing something
else.
We're taking the electrons from
CH to be
the attacking group.
So it's a rearrangement.
It's a hydride shift.
And what pushes the hydride
away, what allows it to do
that, is the fact that these
electrons can go in and form a
very strong CO double bond at
the same time.
And this will remind you, if you
think about it a little
bit, of another reaction we
looked at.
This hydride shift reminds you
of this alkide shift here.
Remember when you had B minus it
was possible for these
electrons to displace the OO.
Remember that's the second step
of the
hydroboration/oxidation process.
So it's the same kind of
reaction.
So it's a rearrangement, and
that gives the carboxylic
acid, but of course, it also
generates hydroxide which
reacts with the carboxylic acid.
So that's the stable product is
the carboxylate anion.
So that's why when you have
hydrogen peroxide there the
aldehyde becomes a carboxylic
acid.
Now here's a problem for you to
work on.
Try doing the same thing--
here we used base catalysis.
Suppose it were acidic
conditions and you had to do
it with acidic catalysis.
Could you draw a mechanism that
gets to the same place.
Of course, it would be
protonated, if it's acidic
rather than basic.
But see if you can put together
a mechanism that's
acid catalyzed that does the
same thing.
Now we've been talking about
electrophilic additions to
carbon-carbon double bonds.
We talked already last semester
about nucleophilic
addition to CO double bonds.
So nucleophile versus
electrophile.
But remember that the addition
to the carbon-carbon double
bond was both electrophilic and
nucleophilic.
So it wouldn't be surprising if
the addition to the CO
double bond is both nucleophilic
and
electrophilic.
So let's just compare it.
So the nucleophilic addition of
methyllithium
to a carbonyl group--
and we'll discuss this more when
we're talking about the
chemistry of carbonyl groups--
is formally quite different
because you add electrophiles
to alkenes.
But this shows you that there's
really quite a
similarity.
So here on top, this is the
transition state for the
addition of methyllithium, so
the yellow or orange thing is
lithium, and this CH3, of
course, is methyl.
So that's it coming down on top
of formaldehyde.
And that's the transition state.
So what's happening is we're
changing partners here with
these electron pairs, and going
toward that product.
So we start with this,
methyllithium and the
carbonyl, and there we have a
HOMO, which is the
lithium-carbon bond, mostly on
carbon-- that doesn't
surprise you.
But notice that it's well set up
to interact with the
pi* of the carbonyl.
And by the same token here's
LUMO+1, a p orbital on the
lithium, a vacant orbital, which
is well set up to
overlap with the red part of a
HOMO.
So again, there are two
electrons that do the trick--
HOMO with LUMO, LUMO with HOMO.
And you get both things
happening at once.
And we'll come back and talk
about that more, but I just
wanted to show you that it's not
a completely different
thing from the addition to
alkenes.
Now we're ready to talk about
metals.
Let me just do a little bit at
the beginning and then we'll
go on next time to talk about
more.
So osmium textroxide, or
permanganate, is osmium, or
manganese minus, in the center
of four oxygens.
And notice that that looks like
ozone, these three atoms
in a row above the two of the
alkene.
So there's its HOMO, and it's
well set up to interact with
the alkene LUMO.
And there's its LUMO, which is
well set up to act with that
alkene HOMO, although I seem to
have messed up the
animation a little bit.
So here we can see it happening.
It gives us osmate ester.
Now notice it forms two bonds at
the same time.
It's like this 1,3-dipole or
cycloaddition.
And that's the osmium analog of
that cyclic acetal that we
looked at before.
So we can imagine water coming
in and breaking it apart to
give a double bond and two OH
groups.
So the product then from that
osmate ester of
hydrolysis is the diol.
So you could make a
carbon-carbon double bond,
break this pi bond and put two
OH's on.
So osmium tetroxide is a very
good reagent for giving that
in high yield.
In other respects, it's not such
a great reagent, and
we'll talk about that next time.